مساعده بريطانيا للاوكرانيين طالما حظيه
بدعم الحكومه البريطانيه لكن خلف هذا
الدعم تخوف من الجيش البريطاني من ان
المساعده العسكريه للقوات الاوكرانيه قد
تاتي على حساب كفاءاتهم وهو ما دفع رئيس
هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
البريطانيه الى التحذير من المضيق قدما
دون مراجعه بخططه وزاره الدفاع التي اعلن
وزيرها بن ويلز في وقت صادق عن نيه
بريطانيا تجويد اوكرانيا باربعه 10 دبابه
من نوع تشالنجر وهو معتبره ساندرياس في
بيان المسرب انه سيضع الجيش البريطاني في
موقف اضعف امام اي تهديدات عسكريه في
المنطقه كما ان ذلك قد يجبر بريطانيا على
التخلف عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها تجاه حلف
الناتو وقد يترك ايضا فجاه في مخزون الجيش
البريطاني من معدات عسكريه
التصريحات هذه بحسب متابعين ربما محاوله
من قبل الجيش لضمان ان وزاره الدفاع
ستستبدل العتاد الممنوح لاوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى حث وزاره الخزانه لتمويل مثل
هكذا تحركات تجنبا لتراجع مستوى الجيش
البريطاني
اعطيني ايميل
[موسيقى]
وسياسيه
مع روسيا لكنني مع ارسال الدعم العسكري
واعتقد انه قد يكون مثيرا للجدل لانه
سيقلب الموازين ويضعنا على خط المواجهه
قدام مني ربما افضل ونحن قدمنا الدعم
المليني وايضا الولايات المتحده
نعلم انهم بحاجه الى تعمل
مهم حتى لو كان رمزيا علينا مساعدتهم وان
كان الام مثيره للجدل لكن مهم جدا تقدم
الدعم المالي والعسكري
نيا بشكل مطلق وخاصه الدعم العسكريه اذا
كانت لدينا الموارد فعلينا ان ندعمهم
وخسائر كبيره نريد ان ينتهي الوضع القائم
وعلينا ايجاد طريقه لوقف الصراع وربما من
خلال الدبلوماسيه
فرقا في نهايه اليوم الامر غير مؤكد امام
عدد الدبابات التي يواجهونها لكنه موقف
سياسيون لاظهار التضامن القيام به حتى لو
انه كان سيجعل الوضع اسوء ويدفع الروس الى
مزيد من العدوانيه